فوضى في قمة عالم التكنولوجيا،
شركة open ai، أحد أفضل اللاعبين
في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي، دخلت في
حالة من الفوضى اليوم، أرسل أكثر من 500 موظف في open aai
خطابًا إلى
مجلس إدارة الشركة يهددون فيه بالاستقالة بسبب إقالة
مجلس الإدارة المفاجئة للرئيس
التنفيذي الشهير لشركة open ai  ربما كانت هناك خلافات بين سام ألمان،
لكن هذه ليست الطريقة التي
يدير بها إحدى أهم الشركات
في عصر الذكاء الاصطناعي على الأقل منذ توليه منصبه يوم
الجمعة. لقد تم تعيين ألمان من قبل شركة مايكروسوفت
التي كانت من أكبر المستثمرين في شركة
مايكروسوفت لإدارة قسم الذكاء الاصطناعي في مايكروسوفت.
تغيير يترك
مستقبل الذكاء الاصطناعي مفتوحًا موضع شك، فقد بلغت قيمته 80
مليار دولار، وهذا شيء
فقده الموظفون الآن، كما تعلمون
في هذا الصدد، إنها شركة رائدة في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي،
وهي شركة أنشأت برنامج دردشة GPT
وهو برنامج يمكنه صياغة خطاب  اكتب
رواية أو قم بإنشاء إجابات للأسئلة
من خلال الاعتماد على ملايين
الأمثلة السابقة لماذا تم طرد ألتمان من قبل
صناعة مجالس إدارة الذكاء الاصطناعي المفتوح. يقول المراقبون إن ذلك كان بمثابة
انقسام بين رؤيته
لمستقبل الذكاء الاصطناعي
والمجالس التي كانت تلك الانقسامات محتدمة
داخل الذكاء الاصطناعي المفتوح.  رأى الناس هذا
المنتج القيم بشكل لا يصدق وأرادوا
المضي قدمًا، وكان الآخرون أكثر
حذرًا قائلين إنه يتعين عليهم أن
يكونوا مسؤولين عن الإنسانية، وبدا أن
ألمان في بعض الأحيان يمتد بين كلا
المعسكرين، كما يقول المحللون داخل الذكاء الاصطناعي المفتوح، كان بعض
أعضاء مجلس الإدارة ينظرون إليه على أنه
عدواني للغاية ويريد ذلك  تسويق
الذكاء الاصطناعي ودفعه للأمام، لكنه
أخبر الكونجرس أيضًا في وقت سابق من هذا العام
عن مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي. أعتقد أنه إذا
سارت هذه التكنولوجيا بشكل خاطئ، فمن الممكن أن تسوء تمامًا،
ونحن قلقون تمامًا بشأن
التأثير الذي يمكن أن يحدثه ذلك على الانتخابات
وإمكانية إنشاء الذكاء الاصطناعي.  تعد
المعلومات الخاطئة مثل التعليقات الملفقة
من المرشحين أو التقارير الإخبارية المزيفة مصدر
قلق كبير مع حلول عام 2024،
ومخاوف أخرى من المحتمل أن تؤدي إلى فقدان الوظائف وأه، كما تعلم،
يتم تهجير الأشخاص من
الاقتصاد على المدى الطويل، ومع ذلك
أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص في
صناعة الذكاء الاصطناعي  على وجه الخصوص، الذين
يشعرون بالقلق إزاء ظهور ما
يسمى الذكاء العام الاصطناعي،
فأنت تعرف هذا النوع من سيناريوهات يوم القيامة
حيث تعلم أن الذكاء الاصطناعي سيسيطر
على العالم ولكن المحللين يقولون إن هذا
متوازن مع
الأشياء الإيجابية المحتملة التي يمكن أن يفعلها الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل
المساعدة في معالجة تغير المناخ
وتحسين صحتنا ما
يفعله الذكاء الاصطناعي هو العثور على الأنماط، وأنت
تعلم أن التكنولوجيا الجيدة جدًا
في العثور على الأنماط يمكن أن تساعدك على معرفة القيام
بأشياء مثل تشخيص الأمراض أو تطوير
اللقاحات. هل الحكومة الفيدرالية مستعدة
لتنظيم الذكاء الاصطناعي وهل
يمكنها ذلك كما يقول المحلل بريان فان؟  هناك
رغبة قوية بين قادة الكونجرس
لتنظيم الذكاء الاصطناعي، لكنه يقول إنهم غير
متأكدين من القواعد التي يجب كتابتها له بعد
لأنهم ما زالوا يتعلمون الكثير
عنه